good to see you again it seems like
every time I talk to you there's a new
crisis last time it was after the
assassination attempt now you're under
house arrest you're back in court
tomorrow
um how are you doing
well
my life is pretty exciting you never
know what's going to happen the next day
it certainly is it's certainly
unpredictable many would think very
dangerous in many different ways for you
just before I came on air today you've
now been in addition to the 150
different violence and Corruption
charges that you're facing they've now
put your name against this murder of a
lawyer who was pressing for a case
against you for sedition uh who was
killed on Tuesday by four gunmen what is
your response to that
Biz look
this case was so frivolous that it
didn't even register on my radar out of
the 150 cases so this guy got killed the
family claimed it was a family feud
the police went over to the house picked
up the son of this guy kept him in
police station for eight hours and then
he changed and said that I had had him
killed and the case is so irrelevant
that you know why would I why would I
kill anyone well why would I kill a
lawyer in a case that is it's one of the
least significant cases out of the 150.
I mean the the fact is this man was
killed on Tuesday the fact is he
obviously he was uh taking Iran was a
legal challenge relating to alleged
sedition but just to be clear you had
nothing to do with what happened or
these gunmen who killed him
because I don't even know the name of
this guy it's Abdul was again I repeat
it is the case study didn't even
register on my on my radar
of course I had nothing to do with it
everyone knows I had nothing to do with
it people in his family know that I have
nothing to do with it
the other charge is Imran is 150 of them
it's a huge amount obviously if you're
convicted of this you'll go to prison
presumably for a long period of time
what do you feel about this I mean
you're back in court tomorrow you'll
just they'll decide whether you can go
back home under house arrest or
presumably whether you will be
incarcerated what is your general view
about what is happening to you
I'm I have 17 bail cases tomorrow
chances are all all the judge has to say
is that one of the bills he refuses to
give me Bill and I go to jail so I'm
mentally prepared but you know Bears
what is happening in Pakistan we are
back to the Dark Ages I mean there's no
rule of law left here
if you what what has been happening to
my party 10
000 of our workers are in jail and they
the the judges give them relief and that
the police picks them up another case so
it is the law of the Jungle right now I
mean it's never happened in this country
before your critics your enemies they
say you're getting what you did to
others in the sense that the military
turned on you but to start with you had
them on your side that you when you came
into office were putting people in
prison who shouldn't have been with
trump top charges and so on you've heard
this charge against you what is your
response to that
you know something first of all this has
never happened in our history what is
happening right now
even during martial laws when there were
military dictators this sort of
Crackdown has never happened I mean you
don't put 10 000 worker people in jail
and and then not pro-journalist one of
our best investigative journalists has
been missing for 20 days and the judges
keep asking him to come bring him to
court the government refuses so look
first of all it's never happened even in
military dictatorship what is happening
now but secondly do you know 95 of the
cases against the opposition are
inherited they were from from the
previous governments in fact when they
were in power
uh there were only five percent of the
cases and it was nothing like what is
going on now there was no no question of
any political victimization there were
ongoing cases and you know
the Judiciary was free the media was
free
this sort of thing has I repeat even in
general martial law nothing like this
ever happened what what will happen
Imran if as you say it's all a stitch up
and you're a victim of of unprecedented
systemic abuse by the the powers that be
now if you end up going to jail for a
long period of time what will happen to
you to your party to the movement to all
of it
look past this today why is this
happening this is happening because my
party
PTI
is now the largest party in Pakistan's
history I mean the ratings of the party
has today
to all the parties on one side they
realize that they they are no match for
this party the movement is so powerful
today and that is the reason why this is
happening because they are now are
petrified the People Who removed me are
petrified that whenever an elections are
supposed to be in October
whenever their elections are my party
will come back into Power hence they are
trying to completely dismantle the party
I mean this sort of how can you put 10
000 people in jail on an arson where a
few hundred people were involved
it was pre-planned they used the pretext
of awesome in some building three or
four buildings to just go after the
entire party having said that Imran
clearly a number of your supporters have
committed acts of violence I I'm
assuming you wouldn't dispute that
I would because you know in 27 years
never has my party committed acts of
violence we have always told our people
to stay within the law now what happened
on this on the ninth when they when they
abducted me from the presence of the
high court
and the way they treated me and the way
the violence and then they were treated
me like a terrorist which the Supreme
Court ruled was unlawful
obviously there was a reaction but the
arson
you know this was not committed by a
working which is like why I keep calling
for an independent judicial inquiry
because even when I was shot nothing
like this happened I mean surely that is
the time when people should have you
know gone up burnt buildings but nothing
happened but this was it was you know
prayers this is what Hitler did in 1933
when the Berlin in Berlin the parliament
was burned you went after the Communists
and Demorest all opposition this is
what's happening right now
Imran on a human level you know I've
spoken to you after people tried to kill
you and they came very close to killing
you that was just six months ago or so
you've got a family you've got these two
young Sons
uh you tweeted recently the only thing I
missed these days is hiking in our
Northern mountains with my sons and that
was a very human thing to tweet and I as
a father of three boys not dissimilar
age to yours now that really resonated
with me how are you doing on a on a
human level
well it's a you know huge sacrifice
because what is happening right now is
we are basically fighting for rule of
law and democracy on the other hand we
now have
uh we are heading towards the worst type
of dictatorship it's a Banana Republic
right now where the judges now are no
longer independent they are threatened
media is completely muzzled my name is
not allowed to be mentioned on the media
and
you can't demolish the biggest political
party by by the the steps they've taken
these Draconian steps so therefore what
is that threat is that democracy our
future so there's the you know it is a
this has been one of the most toughest
years of my life because not just there
wasn't one assassination attempt on the
18th of March there was a second
assassination attempt and not just that
on the cases and my workers actually the
boys who are suffering are my workers
they're crammed in these jails they
don't get proper food and there's you
know even our lawyers are not allowed to
see them but though even worse the women
first time women started participating
in politics with my party first time
women took part in peaceful protest and
the way they went after the women I mean
they are if you see the some of the
videos of the way they beat up women and
they put them in jails Who were or no
woman was involved in violence yet there
were hundreds put in jails are you able
to see your sons
no I can't this is too dangerous attack
from me to ask them to come over uh and
you know I'm confident that this is this
is not going to last very long because
the system cannot take this much longer
the Judiciary is is overall right now
it's cowed down
but the Judiciary has a past 15 years
it's asserted its independence so at the
moment it's it's you know the the terror
which is in Pakistan is a reign of
terror I mean people are frightened
people are picked up in the middle of
the night it's like in in you know in
the in the Nazi Germany the police
badges into a home and if they don't
find the guy who's who they're looking
for PTI and most of them are now hiding
on jail they pick up relatives I mean
collect a punishment this this has never
happened in our country before you know
Imran each time I talk to you I I'm
always reminded that you know I spent my
formative years down at Sussex County
cricket ground watching you bowling
magnificently for Sussex and you were
one of my sort of Heroes then cricketing
Heroes do you ever wish you just hadn't
gone into politics I mean serious
question given the impact on your life
the dangers the threats the
assassination attempts and so on do you
ever wish you'd just you know had an
easier life
but bears look in Pakistan they're two
ways one is when you go into Politics as
a political career in my opinion
it is the worst career to ever choose I
would never suggest Politics as a career
to anyone as a career secondly is the
politics where you you are so privileged
I had more respect than any other
Pakistani
and I tried I what I wanted to do was to
what I by the way what I first
saw and admired in England when I went
there as a teenager rule of law we never
had rule of Royal in this country
because we had dictatorship either we
had dictation dictatorship or two
families but they never allowed people
to have rule of law where people
fundamental rights were protected and as
a result
the country is not we don't we never
knew Freedom real Freedom first time I
saw was in England when I went as a
teenager and I discovered how rule of
law and fundamental rights Liberator
whole people
so Mayan movement started 27 years ago I
realized that unless we have rule of law
we have no future
so this is a 27 year old Mission but
even if it costs you your your Liberty
or even your life it's worth it here
well my life is at serious threat
because the worry they are facing is
that even if they put me in jail the
popularity of the party has crossed 70
today bills never has a party been so
popular so they are scared that even if
I I'm in jail the party would wear hence
there were these two assassination
attempts on me
I would say that the support from world
leaders has been pretty deafening with
its silence in the main
do you wish you'd have more vocal
support from maybe the British prime
minister which is soon like the American
President Joe Biden would that be
helpful
look you're not bears at my age three
and a half years as prime minister I
discovered one thing that this morality
and the the so-called Western values
about democracy constitutionalism rule
of law fundamental rights against
custodial torture all that is happening
in Pakistan today yet I think the
interests of the the powers Britain the
U.S I think they are more aligned with
our military
uh uh for whatever reasons maybe because
they're supporting them in Ukraine
um I always wanted an independent
foreign policy because I
80 000 pakistanis died when we joined
the U.S war on terror and I was against
it so I think maybe that they feel that
their interests are more served by by
the current regime and whenever that
happens you know all these professed
values go out of the window I mean
Richie sunak is currently in Washington
with President Biden what's your message
to both of them if they're watching this
my message is simple
firstly countries only uh sort their
problems out from within but
the professed values of United States
and United Kingdom
I repeat is democracy is fundamental
rights rule of law I mean whatever they
criticize Hong Kong or China with the
uyghurs or Russia they always talk about
the lack of Human Rights and fundamental
rights and lack of democracy but here
here's one standard democracy and all
this all these values are being violated
yet not a word from them but you know I
didn't really expect much I do what I
expected more and is gradually happening
in the western media because the media
is really
beginning to realize what's going on in
this country
well everyone you will always have a
birth on Piers Morgan uncensored I've
spoken to you numerous times in the last
year it's been a quite extraordinary
period in your life
um and I'm living it vicariously sitting
here safely in London I wish you all the
very best and hope next time I talk to
you it's in in a slightly calmer
circumstance inshallah thank you